en un vídeo anterior vimos que si
teníamos alguna línea que está definida
de la siguiente forma nuestra línea el
decide hacerlo con un color mucho más
claro que nuestra línea l eran todos los
múltiplos de algún vector b y cuando
digo todos los múltiplos son todos
verdad son todos los múltiplos sobre la
línea o sobre la recta real verdad
entonces ya que definimos esta línea
también definimos una transformación que
de hecho le llamamos la proyección sobre
nuestra línea l que de hecho era una
función que iba de nuestro espacio rn a
rn verdad tomamos un vector en rn y lo
apachurra vamos o justamente lo
proyectamos sobre nuestra línea que vive
también en rn de hecho sabemos una
fórmula para la proyección del vector x
sobre la línea l no es otra cosa más que
x punto b
sobre de punto b ok por el vector de
donde ves este mismo generador de la
línea ok entonces lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ahondar un poquito más en
las ideas que hay detrás de las
proyecciones y llegar a demostrar una
propiedad muy importante que ya veremos
más adelante pero algo que ya quizás te
habrás dado cuenta aquí que te estarás
que estarás notando es bueno quienes ve
punto gay de hecho en general sabemos
que si tenemos x x para cualquier vector
esto no es otra cosa más que la norma al
cuadrado de x verdad entonces de punto b
no es otra cosa bueno lo demás lo
dejamos igual que esto es x punto b
sobre de punto b que es la norma al
cuadrado de b ok
y todo esto multiplica a nuestro vector
de esto es un escalar que multiplica a b
ahora bien qué pasaría hay que hay que
preguntarnos lo siguiente qué pasaría si
si este b en particular que nos tomamos
tienen norma igual
es decir qué pasaría si la norma debe es
igual a 1 es decir estamos pensando que
b es un vector unitario es un vector
unitario en el mismo sentido que lo
vimos en el vídeo correspondiente donde
hablamos justamente de los vectores
unitarios ok entonces si si la norma
debe fuera unitario tendríamos que esta
expresión de aquí simplemente como este
es uno se reescribe como x punto d por
el vector b ok y lo cual es una
expresión sumamente sencilla verdad es
es muy fácil acordarse cuando uno tiene
un generador de una recta que tiene
norma 1 ahora el detalle cuando vimos el
vídeo de vectores unitarios es que
siempre podemos dar 1 y vamos a hacer un
ejemplo un dibujo para para ejemplificar
esto tenemos aquí
digamos nuestros ejes esto lo estoy
pintando en enredos aunque por supuesto
todo esto lo podemos extender a rn
verdad y aquí tenemos nuestra línea y
digamos que quien genera esta línea es
un vector b
este es mi vector be y que además éste
no tiene normal norma unitaria es decir
la norma de este vector es distinta de 1
sin embargo ya vimos en ese vídeo de
vectores unitarios quedado cualquier
vector siempre puede uno encontrar otro
que le de hecho le poníamos este este
gorrito gracioso simplemente por tomar
este vector y dividirlo por su norma
verdad dividimos por su nombre por su
norma al vector y entonces éste si ya
tiene norma unitaria y de hecho como
como este como como como b es un
múltiplo de v entonces la línea generada
por b es exactamente la misma generada
por u verdad lo que tenemos es que
nuestra línea l
simplemente es la línea generada por
ahora nuestro vector unitario y verdad
pues si digo si teníamos todos los
múltiplos de b y v son múltiplo de b
pues entonces también tendremos todos
los múltiplos de v y de esta forma
entonces podemos concluir que nuestra
proyección la proyección sobre nuestra
línea l de cualquier vector x ya tiene
una forma sencilla y de hecho es x punto
que multiplica al vector y muy bien
entonces esto de aquí por ejemplo si lo
utilizamos en los vectores que
utilizamos en el vídeo anterior en el
vídeo anterior teníamos el vector b que
era el vector 2 1
el vector x verdad que era el vector 23
es decir podríamos pensar que esta línea
es la generada por el vector 21 y que
queremos proyectar un vector digamos x
que es el 23 digo no no no sé si
exactamente así se pintarían estos dos
vectores pero lo que quiero que quede
claro es la idea de que lo que queremos
hacer verdad entonces lo que necesitamos
es calcular primero la norma de b
y la norma debe es fácil de calcular
porque simplemente es la raíz cuadrada
de la suma de los cuadrados de las
entradas es decir de 2 al cuadrado de 2
al cuadrado más 1 al cuadrado y esto es
la raíz cuadrada de 5 así que nuestro
vector un unitario va a ser 1 entre la
norma que sería 1 entre la raíz de 5 por
el vector 21 ok y entonces este es
nuestro vector unitario y por el vídeo
que hicimos siempre podemos dar un
vector unitario siempre lo podemos
garantizar entonces si yo tengo
inicialmente una línea que es generada
por un vector de la definición de la
proyección puede parecer en principio
más o menos complicada pero si nuestro
generador de la recta es tiene es
unitario es decir tiene norma 1 entonces
esta expresión se simplifica muchísimo a
simplemente a simplemente esto de aquí x
punto u por el vector u donde es el
vector unitario muy bien entonces ya que
tenemos esto tú dirás oye ya me has
hablado lo suficiente de las
proyecciones ya me dijiste que es una
transformación lo que no sabemos hasta
este momento es si dicha transformación
es lineal aunque entonces lo que no
sabemos decir es una transformación
formación lineal y eso es lo que vamos a
ver justamente ahorita vamos a demostrar
que si es una transformación lineal y
para eso lo que vamos a hacer es ver que
se cumplen las dos propiedades es decir
vamos a tomarnos la proyección la
proyección sobre l de una suma de
vectores
y vamos a ver que esto es la proyección
de a más la proyección bebé entonces
esto por definición si si si tenemos un
generador de l que es un vector unitario
ya vamos a suponer que es unitario
entonces esto simplemente es además ve
que es el que juega el papel de x en
este en este ejemplo punto y ok y todo
esto multiplica a mi vector y ahora bien
este producto punto se distribuye verdad
por propiedades del producto punto esto
es a punto y más b punto
y esto multiplica a nuestro vector y
nuevamente si tenemos una suma de
escalares que multiplica a un vector por
las propiedades de los vectores tenemos
que esto es apuntó que multiplica a uno
más
vamos a ponerlo a punto
que multiplica al vector u y esto ya
está gritando a leguas que es lo que
estamos encontrando porque esto de aquí
no es otra cosa más que la proyección
sobre l de nuestro vector a verdad esto
es por definición aquí está la
definición simplemente en vez de x
ponemos a y esto de aquí no es otra cosa
más que la proyección sobre nuestra
línea l del vector b ok entonces ya
tenemos la primera condición de que la
proyección de una suma en efecto es la
suma de las proyecciones entonces eso es
apenas la mitad del trabajo necesitamos
también demostrar que si tenemos la
proyección la proyección sobre l de un
múltiplo de un vector déjenme ponerle
como estábamos trabajando esto debería
ser el la constante que multiplica a la
proyección de a pero bueno esto por
definición es sea punto que multiplica a
nuestro vector u y nuevamente por
propiedades del producto punto las
constantes pueden salirse del producto
punto entonces esto este veces apuntó
que multiplica y esto esto de aquí no es
otra cosa más que esto es la proyección
sobre l de a que está haciendo x c
entonces tenemos de veces la proyección
sobre l del vector a y como esta es la
segunda condición que se debe cumplir
para que una transformación sea lineal
tenemos esta y tenemos esta entonces si
esta transformación en efecto es lineal
pero hay algo más importante que sabemos
de las transformaciones lineales y que
esencialmente es mi punto central de
este vídeo y es que por ser lineal tiene
forzosamente una representación
matricial es decir nosotros sabemos si
que la proyección sobre la línea l del
vector x se puede calcular como x punto
u que multiplica al vector y ok pero
pero por ser una transformación lineal
tenemos de gratis que existe una matriz
a que al multiplicarlo por x
está esta transformación y de hecho
sabemos que la matriz a es de 2 x 2
verdad es de 2 x 2 porque tenemos que la
proyección va de r2 a r2
entonces
vamos a ver si nosotros tenemos esto de
aquí de hecho aquí lo voy a trabajar
dije de dos por dos estoy pensando
entonces que la proyección sobre la
línea l del vector x es una función que
va de r 2 en el rededor sin embargo esta
idea que voy a presentar la puede no
extender a rn donde la gente puede ser
tan grande como quieras de 724.000 lo
que sé yo lo que quiero hacer aquí con
este ejemplo es fijar las ideas ok
quiero fijar las ideas de cómo se
comporta la matriz de una proyección y
para hacer eso sabemos muy bien que
necesitamos ver hacia dónde va a dar la
base canónica es decir qué pasa si yo me
tomo la identidad la identidad en este
caso de 2 x 2 y empiezo a aplicarle la
transformación si yo aplico la
transformación voy a tener que entonces
mi matriz a es aquella que tiene como
columnas a la imagen de la de la
transformación que en este caso es una
proyección de la base canónica es decir
d
dos vectores que forman la base canónica
entonces si aplicamos la transformación
al primer vector al 10 estaríamos
diciendo que tengo 1010 punto y que
digamos que nuestro vector y el vector
unitario va a ser un 1 o 2
vamos a pensar que se escribe de esa
forma y entonces al aplicar la
proyección al vector 10 tenemos 10
puntos que es un 1
o dos y todo esto multiplica al vector
que es un 12 esta es mi primera columna
vámonos con la segunda la segunda
columna es aplicar la transformación al
0 1 ok
si dije el 10 anteriormente espero que
si él aquí aplicamos la transformación a
10 vamos a aplicarlo a 0 1 ok entonces
tengo 0 1
punto 1 1 2
y todo esto multiplica al vector 1 1 2
entonces aquí ya tenemos sin desarrollar
mi matriz que me interesa
así que vamos a vamos a desarrollarlo
solo que tenemos que calcular pero ya
está aquí verdad porque lo podemos de
hecho lo podemos expresar como
como bueno antes de antes de expresar lo
vamos a terminar de decir quién es esta
matriz aquí este producto punto nos da
uno por s con perdón 1.1 por 10 por 1 2
es uno que multiplica a
a este vector verdad entonces de hecho
y hacerlo más espaciado entonces si
nosotros desarrollamos a la matriz a
esto es una verdad dijimos que es uno
que multiplica el vector 112 ok y el
otro la otra columna va a ser cero por
uno es cero más uno por dos simplemente
nos da dos que multiplica a un 12 ok
entonces esta matriz es la que ya
tenemos y es fácil de calcular verdad
porque uno por uno es uno al cuadrado 1
por 2 es uno o dos y dos por uno es 12
verdad simplemente cambiando el orden y
12 por 12 es u2 al cuadrado muy bien
entonces esta es la matriz asociada a la
transformación de la proyección verdad
es decir si tú me das un vector unitario
yo te doy la transformación asociada a
la proyección sobre la línea que genera
ese vector unitario eso dicho en muchas
palabras verdad entonces en este
el vector unitario era hui y era uno
entre la raíz de 5 por el 21 que lo
podemos poner como 2 sobre la raíz de 5
y 1 sobre la raíz de 5 ok entonces
en este caso particular en donde el
vector y es este entonces lo podemos
sustituir y la matriz que me queda es 1
al cuadrado que es 4 sobre 5 que 1 por
12 es 2 por 1 2 y raíz de 5 por raíz de
5 35 verdad es raíz de 5 al cuadrado
aquí vamos a tener 1 por 2 que es 2
sobre 5 y 12 al cuadrado es 1 sobre la
raíz de 5 al cuadrado es 1 sobre 5 ok
entonces ya que tenemos este vector
unitario tenemos la matriz asociada al
atrae a la ala a la proyección sobre la
línea que genera entonces cómo se vería
esto más o menos
a ponerlo así si éste es nuestro vector
b
y hacerlo un poco más grande si éste es
mi vector de el que inicialmente tenía y
estoy considerando la recta generada por
este por este vector ok entonces yo
necesito achicarlo para hacerlo más
pequeño hasta definir mi vector y que es
el 1 sobre la raíz de 5 del 21
el 21 verdad este es mi vector unitario
y lo que tenemos finalmente es que la
proyección la proyección sobre el de
cualquier vector x si tenemos una
fórmula sencilla de calcularlo pero
además tenemos una forma matricial lo
cual es bastante bonito verdad que
podamos ver esta transformación como una
matriz por un vector esta matriz por el
vector x verdad es muy bonito este
resultado es decir si tú tienes aquí un
vector x ok si tú tienes aquí un vector
x en realidad con esta fórmula de
matricial podemos encontrar el vector
que se encuentra sobre la línea que es
la sombra o la proyección de nuestro
vector x si nosotros tenemos por ejemplo
este otro vector de la misma forma
podemos calcular quién es su proyección
sobre esta línea o si tenemos no sé
alguno
otro por acá también tendremos quien en
su proyección pero bueno de todas formas
creo que esto fue bastante bonito